our people dying and suffering
needlessly because all these committees
and all these rules and what happens if
people just start saying like [ __ ] you
I'm gonna do it anyway and what if
people start getting cured
Josiah Zener is a scientist biohacker
and founder of the biotech company
Theoden which supplies low-cost crisper
kits for the consumer market CRISPR is a
gene editing system that allows
scientists to modify the DNA of
organisms ranging from bacteria to
plants and fungus to human beings we
visited Zehner in his garage lab to
discuss the implications of bringing
CRISPR to the masses and why he believes
that unregulated decentralized
experimentation will lead to the next
giant scientific breakthroughs give me a
little bit of your background how did
you learn to do this kind of thing in
the first place and what got you
interested in bio hacking it all started
probably about eight years ago when I
was in graduate school over in Chicago
and I always wanted to do these
experiments and my boss he's got to
write grants and get data for the grants
and all this stuff and he'll always be
like I really know that doesn't seem too
interesting why don't you do what I say
because it's the best idea
at one point you worked at NASA actually
and now you're working out of your
garage and your kitchen why is that
actually when I told my mom that I was
going to leave NASA she kind of freaked
out she was like why would you ever
leave NASA you know because I guess it's
most people's dream to work there and it
kind of was almost my dream at one point
in time to work at NASA and be be a
scientist you know work on getting us to
Mars and all this stuff and then I wound
up there and it's all those things that
people say about the government that
like you have to fill out a million
forms for everything they waste a ton of
money and nobody actually does any work
they actually told me one time like you
know what you work every day in the lab
and that's really dangerous because you
could get injured or something like that
so can you take like one day a week and
not work and like go in your office and
like maybe answer
emails or something like that I'm like
you're literally asking me not to work
one day a week like what that's what I
kind of figured out like the government
sometimes doesn't make sense it's just
like do this because somebody said so
what were the kinds of things that you
were proposing that you wanted to do
that your boss was kind of that I don't
know about that I wanted to see how I
could interface this protein this
genetically engineered protein from oat
from the oak plant how could it how I
could interface it with like electronics
so it's this light responsive protein
and I wanted to interface it with
electronics and like build a little
device it's kind of cool but there's
really like I guess some would say no
scientific like outcome of that right
you can't get write a paper there's
really no hypotheses I'm testing I'm
just trying to build something cool and
I was like well I want to work on these
things I want to do these things how do
I make it so I can do that so I started
looking around for supplies and I found
out you can buy all this stuff online
but it's like at all these different
places and it takes you forever just to
find the best price or where to get this
or where to get that and that's kind of
when was the genesis for the Odin could
you describe the Odin project a little
bit what exactly is your product we're
trying to democratize science basically
has always been you know you have to
have a PhD or you have to have certain
skill set and then you have to convince
somebody who has a PhD to let you work
with them what if everybody could do
science taking tools like CRISPR that
are these cutting-edge genetic
engineering tools oh wow this is like
the hottest science that somebody can do
and then saying look we're making it
simple enough that almost anybody could
do it what's an example of someone who
buys one of your kits might use it for
how to engineer yeast for beers so he's
editing different genes in the genome
things that give a flavor to give it
smells and all these other things to
make his own custom beers so we can take
the CRISPR technology and make it
applied to basically like something I
mean
I drink beer a lot something people
experience like every day and what do
you say to people who might think okay
you're trying to democratize science
that's really dangerous what you're
selling is basically little Pandora's
boxes that any Yahoo can open and kind
of ruin the world with first I respond
by asking the person you know do you
know what DNA is and they say no then
usually the conversation ends there
or if they struggle to explain it but
the reality is it's so hard to engineer
something to be dangerous and these kits
also they don't allow people to engineer
things like viruses or something like
that but if you think about the bacteria
the bacteria that are dangerous have
evolved over billions of years and it's
required bacteria covering the planet
just to get some of these toxins that
would affect mammals or other organisms
just not you know anything that should
be worried about even thought about how
do you feel about the government
regulation around this area of science
right now because like biohackers and
people doing science at home is so new
there's really not much regulation at
the moment people have a lot of freedom
to do some people are even getting mad
academics and people working in
universities because they have
institutional guidelines that they have
to follow so the government doesn't
impose certain guidelines on research
but the institution the university
imposes guidelines on those researchers
then which if you're working in your
garage or your institution is basically
you and maybe your friends and stuff
like that so there's no regulation I
think that the government probably in
the future sometime will try to regulate
it I'm kind of I don't know I guess one
of those people who food just doesn't
want any regulation I'm just like I just
let people do science what do you think
would be some of the drawbacks if the
government did come in with a heavy hand
to start regulating this I think
innovation is the number one if you
compare it to like when computers first
started getting big
and people were just you know coating up
stuff and hacking away on their
computers at home Linux operating system
came out of it so much free open-source
software that we all use now came out of
it and that innovation just spread
everywhere
you used biohacking and self
experimentation to actually improve a
problem in your own life could you talk
about that a little bit I have lots of
gastrointestinal problems you know lots
of nasty stuff have to go to the NGO
four times a day blood coming out other
gross stuff that is not good has really
kind of limited some some areas of my
life I did like a full body microbiome
transplant so microbiome is the bacteria
that are all over your body in your gut
on your skin in your nose mouth
everything I found a healthy donor I
took you know poop samples and other
samples skin samples and all these
things and basically sterilized myself
with antibiotics and transplanted his
microbiome to my body and afterward a
lot of the problems I had just cleared
up when you say you transferred his
sample to your body how does that work
for fecal samples it got fresh samples
totally not to eat anything crazy and
then basically put those in capsules and
you just take them right you know not
everyone is going to be willing to like
put their buddy's [ __ ] in a pill and eat
it so what can we learn from this
experience
like what's the wider lesson there are a
lot of technologies like CRISPR that are
100% proven but can be used to treat
people or like fecal transplants that
aren't proven because good luck getting
institutional approval are we lagging
behind because of all these committees
and all these rules are people dying and
suffering needlessly because all these
committees and all these rules and what
happens if people just start saying like
[ __ ] you I'm going to do it anyway and
what if people start getting cured where
do you see this going in five or ten
years you have any speculation if you
ask people like what what would people
do with electricity you know oh they get
to light their how
so candles are just fine right and now
like look it look at this look at what
we can do with electricity and same
thing with computers when they were in
huge computers and labs everybody's like
oh what will people do with computers oh
who knows and now we have like freaking
computer in our pocket with like all the
worlds and knowledge that we have access
to like who could have predicted that
nobody so I just like to think like
there are people out there that are
going to blow our minds and I don't
quite know what they're going to do yet
but I know they're going to blow our
minds but by giving them the access to
these tools to this technology I think
that's the major way it's going to
happen to give people knowledge and let
them change the world
Josiah's Ainur thank you very much for
talking to us yeah it's nice talking to
you also for recent TV I'm Zack Weiss
Miller that we can't make organisms that
are more efficient than existing I don't
think is is correct because Nature
doesn't have DNA laser printers and we
do one of the reasons that various
commenters and the authorities tend to
be anxious about the future is that
things are in a sense getting out of
control